aber damit ist herzlich willkommen hier
heute mal wieder zu einer neuen nicht
lachen challenge auf meinem kanal
allerdings mal wieder nicht mit mir
alleine sondern auch mit schreien der
begeisterung auf keinen fall flex flex
banane
[Gelächter]
ex partner nach dem ersten clip habe ich
mir wirklich gedacht wo wir haben noch
nicht gelacht richtig gut wir haben
beide die challenge verstanden dann der
zweite clip max flex banerjee war das
egal
das kenne ich schon
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
michael jackson ist einfach unglaublich
sagt ich habe mich erst die heißt ja
noch nie heißt er nochmal jeremy freer
eine ist für mich viel zu fett die
andere sieht aus als wäre sie gerade von
außen fahrbahn verrichtet gekommen
[Gelächter]
so entstand so wildnis die strengsten
eltern der welt oder so wird es für dich
auf eine option da hinzugehen
ja meine marke mich schaut immer mal
irgendwo rein stecken aber ich bin noch
hier
ich wollte dich schon immer meinen
reinstecken okay wenn sie mich zu sein
[Gelächter]
wenn die nerven er heute den einzelne
fresse würdest du mit der person
gegenüber was ankommt jahrhundert so
richtig was du da so hasst nein
[Musik]
da kann etwas haben gedanken ich weiß
halt nicht was seine mission ist der typ
il will doch augenscheinlich allen
irgendwie fragrance tipps beibringen
also irgendwie sagen so hey das parfum
ist gut und das überhaupt hat santander
wieder aufwärts haye war ist jetzt auch
mal so wie jerry fragrance ein paar
sekunden später
[Musik]
mir ist schwindelig gerade als mir ist
unnormal schwindelig ich habe mich
lockert 70 mal im kreis gedreht
ich habe ja elf deutsche bewiesen dass
es geht das ist ja meine mission to be
so gesehen was da stand tobias wenn er
mit schering geschafft die sache sie
haben ein kumpel der als tobias und das
könnte ein zu eins
[Musik]
das wieder du das gefühl dass bis 1 zu
vor allem der typ heißt cache rentfort
wenn ihr einfach auf tik tok weist seine
mutter ob draußen alte bude also warum
soll auf einmal einen aschenbecher seien
ja so voll ist das war schäferhund
letztens man mit denen betrunkene leute
bei gesamten vorgarten dass man locker
alles freunde von eurem hund ein broker
das erste was mache es direkt alle
freunde schicken und einen tag später
wieder depression schieben weil nix
läuft einfach die wahrheit ich weiß ich
also keine ahnung leute ihr könnt das
immer gerne und in die kommentare
schreiben was macht ihr wenn diese ganze
quarantänezeit vorbei ist ich weiß nicht
was ich dann mache ich werde weiter so
schön also mittlerweile gefällt mir der
zu starken ja die sache ist ich werde
selbst wieder freunde treffen und weiter
uns fort aber so viel spam jetzt nicht
verändern ja ich will unbedingt in den
freizeitpark warum willst du unbedingt
im freizeitpark ich möchte die sache ist
du bist wahrscheinlich auch gar nicht
groß genug dafür ja für manche muss man
halt ein 60 sein und da kann ich
wirklich nicht drauf gehen wir nicht zu
klein
[Musik]
jetzt haben wir wieder für eine für
clips drin
mit einem schaf auf zurück das war in
köln
jeremy freer wieder soll ich noch play
drücken direkte denkt dass es mich das
ist doch nicht richtig sein wie du musst
mal mit uns zusammen hör nicht lange
challenge machen
luca woher kommt ihr auf einmal ich weiß
ist nicht das ist das dritte mal dass er
dieser compilation aber er ist anderes
wichtiger würdest du dir was mit jeremy
frequenz vorstellen können sagt warum
nicht schnell und du ja klar
safed mein traummann absolut sowie der
tanzt alter direkt verliebt da kann man
nicht nein sagen
[Musik]
hat sie gerade gesagt junge warum gehst
du direkt auf vater bei dem wort kann
auch maskulin seien eine männliche ja
man kann ja warum
oder ist gar um eine frage ja
[Musik]
die wahrheit oder wurde wenn ich die
wahrheit was macht er da vor allem hartz
falsch geschrieben und gezahlt falsch
geschrieben
da denkst hat vielmehr auch ein job für
dich ja dann schon sein kann nicht
sagten ihm einen zu niedrigen lohn fürs
leben niemals nie sagen vielleicht
appenzeller bahnen mit grip mit
düsseldorf hier lebte 15 jährige fabian
firma nach seinem gesetzen die in meinem
leben gibt es nur eine regel mein regeln
[Applaus]
[Musik]
in seinem in seinem leben gibt so eine
regel
seine reliquien schwimmern aus
düsseldorf du hast du hast also schön
kräftig hab kreuzstraße ein kräftespiel
es erst mal gar keinen helden hoch und
so steht mir schön capstone schön kräfte
sparen konnte man die schnauze wie geil
ist und dass mitte zusammengeschnitten
dass zusammengeschnitten
aber dann geht mir einfach nur ein
kräftig
ich möchte mich jetzt hier offiziell
beschweren
das kann nicht sein ich musste ich
gerade noch fünf cent reinstecken ich
hatte leider nur noch zehn cent ich
stecke den zehn zentren er sagt okay und
gibt mir kein wechsel geht wo sind meine
ich höre das ist richtig deutsch
das ist richtig deutsch und künftig
selbst kennen das gar nicht dieses
halten ich bin dafür dass entlassen
juckt mich wenn du hast halt auch nicht
mal 15
das ist so dass die schüler auch wenn
sie persönlich begrüßt werden gerne in
die schule kommen was der hat der
begrüßt jeden einzelnen schüler morgens
mit morgen der ist der ansicht dass man
dann als schüler lieber zur schule geht
der vorkommen das ist also werde ich in
der psychiatrie da wäre ich weiß doch
bis zur neunten klasse musste man immer
ausstehen guten morgen frau maja wo man
muss dir immer aufstehen und dazu singen
einfach ein traum
der kern des teams kenne ich das kenne
ich den tag
das ist hundertprozentig so gut waren da
wie gold ich schön wenn man hat nur
dieses rushing galt aus diese reichen
diese packungen oder moped der orbit
soll ich mal ganz gut gegen den
betrieben werfen bei uns wurde falls
gaben einfach wie diamanten gehandelt
als er diese unfalls gab es das war
anders das war anders
2 und audiologischen gefallen können ich
fand die orangen am krassesten aber das
war wirklich das wort bounce gehandelt
wie mobile ist mit auf dem möchte aber
nur endlich reden damit eben mein
englisch verbessern
[Musik]
das bist du einfach als susan rice sagte
jetzt wieder ein satz auf deutsch
übersetzt mitte auf englisch okay ich
war heute im supermarkt milch und eier
kaufen supermarkt in hall bei mccann was
nun mal und lex sprachenlernen ich habe
von aqua gestellt und alu kommt am tag
an der stelle mich heutigen nicht lachen
steht jetzt allerdings auch beenden
meine lieben freunde wenn es euch
gefallen hat dann das gerne einen daumen
hoch unter dem video ihr da schreibt uns
gerne in die kommentare ob hier sah was
soll die leute in die kommentare
schreiben
die sollen dann stand schreiben was sie
nach der quarantäne machen
die kommentare grasser handy du hast
aufgepasst und jetzt befinden wir uns ja
auch schon im auto meine lieben freunde
hier oben findet ihr ein smiley einige
werdet wenn ihr darauf könnt ihr meinen
kanal kostenlos abonnieren verpasst
keine videos mehr und hier unten findet
ihr die letzte nicht lachen challenge
eingeblendet auch wieder mit sandra da
haben wir ja auch wieder die challenge
nicht so ganz verstanden eine menge rum
gelacht klick das an